lately it's just been a lot of riding
non-stop writing revising and because
I'm working for a couple of different
channels I do my own merchandising so
there's always shipping shirts and
advertising them social media and tons
and tons of meetings are always meeting
with people trying to either collaborate
or see what other opportunities are and
lots of shooting I shoot a lot and I'm
on set a lot I don't know how I balance
any of it it's actually kind of hard
sometimes I get overwhelmed but usually
my to-do list and my calendar keep me
sane and I love crossing things off my
to do this so that really keeps me
motivated sometimes I add something just
like across it all check my emails oh
there I did it to the news I mean it
started I was like boredom and wanting
to get my work out there it's constantly
on Facebook and it was addicting and
felt like I should find a way to make it
productive and I came up with the idea
to do like a soap opera of what it's
like to be black at Stanford it was like
a mockumentary style and it started
spreading and I was like oh my gosh this
is a great medium and maybe I could use
this show and show the response to it
and turn it into a television show and
that didn't work out and but my second
series I was like okay I'm gonna really
really focus on this I'm gonna put it on
every week at the same time and we're
gonna promote the hell out of it
we got through a week and then hopefully
I'll get televisions attention with
awkward black girl I was like you know
what effort I know that no one's gonna
go with this idea I'm just gonna put it
out for the web and have that audience
and my friends and family appreciate it
and of course that's the one that like
really catapulted me in terms of digital
success and so now I'm thinking long
term where I want to produce content
more content and I want to showcase more
people of color in terms of stories and
and actors on the web so that's not
going out I usually go to the bathroom
and come up with an idea there and when
I'm in the shower come up with the most
ideas and then I write them down and
then I'll develop them either a couple
weeks later or years later but a lot of
the stuff that I'm producing right now
is stuff that I just wrote down in a
notebook two years ago and it was like
oh now I have an opportunity producer
and let me do them but even reading
articles sometimes funny articles own
spire-like movies or different story
lines but I just when I when I come up
with an idea I just have to be in the
right mindset to execute it I love
writing and producing my own content
because you get to I mean you get to see
it from start to finish you get to
ensure that it's properly told in your
own voice whereas I think before I was
satisfied with writing and just giving
it off to someone but I don't think I
could ever do that now even with the
project that I just wrote I was like
okay I'm just gonna write all these
episodes and then give it to somebody
and I'll be free but I can't do that
anymore especially having done that
having written something and executed to
myself and knowing I have a particular
vision that I can actually execute like
why not do it but I really love watching
other people who are great at it like to
yourself there's nothing more satisfying
than watching someone who's good at what
they do bring your your stuff to live
well I really look for three things one
if it's unique or told of me a unique
way to if it makes me laugh or brings up
some sort of emotion and three of it
fits within what I think is my sort of
brand of storytelling in comedy so even
if it's like funny and amazing but it
doesn't because it wouldn't necessarily
resonate with my audience I don't I
wouldn't go after that I would support
it but I wouldn't
got a chance I would see the cheese and
leaning but your awkward moment what's
the protocol for repeatedly running into
someone at a stop sign
no seriously what the is it you
took that's great because well one I
really really love the instant feedback
like you can know within seconds or
minutes like whether or not people are
feeling yourself and the idea that you
can put out so much different stuff like
you can try you can literally experiment
as much as you want to and people will
watch I think having that having your
own audience and being able to cater to
a specific audience and and try to
expand the way that we tell stories the
way that we interact with with a lot of
the viewers is just amazing to me
sometimes they're really helpful they'd
be like oh my gosh you need to like and
I'm not pulling this character it
doesn't seem like he's developed over oh
I want to see more of this and so in
that way when I was shooting episodes
like monthly I was able to incorporate
what some of their feedback into what I
was writing but now you know I'm writing
and shooting a lot of things in advance
so it's just like up if you don't like
it sorry I just I can't help you there
but it's really really just great to to
get the feedback and then and our
viewers actually fund a lot of content
to they donate they spread the word like
they're the most precious part of this
whole experience it's kind of easy to
tell when something is constructive and
when something is like just stupid and
so it's kind of easy to filter out like
okay this person is just saying you suck
go die and kill yourself I can't really
do anything but this person is actually
seems to know that seems to be in tune
with how stories work how characters
work and I mean I want to in a sense
cater to that audience
I listen I'm gonna listen to everything
sometimes people will make good
suggestions about like how a story can
go but I'd be like no I'm set in my ways
it's gonna happen this way
so it just depends depends on what you
want to listen to it's allowed me to be
independent and help me to become an
entrepreneur in a sense and it's it's
just providing me so many opportunities
that I wouldn't be able to do like five
ten years ago it's just provided the
platform and I'm yeah I'm indebted to
you too not really though I'm not gonna
pay them am i dating the founder of the
KKK why all the attention
you survived the unique platform for the
underserved
so like earlier we're not really
represented in mainstream media in terms
of film and television and a lot of
content creators can go online and say
you know if I'm not accepted here then I
know that I can find an avi audience
that's starving for content and starving
to see a representation of themselves
and so YouTube has provided that
opportunity YouTube has provided a bank
gateway advice that I give women
creators is just to do it and to
collaborate with people are just as
passionate as you are because I wouldn't
have been anywhere if I didn't have you
know great people who are thorough and
who are smart and who believe in what
I'm doing and I think that that's
important to have a really good team
around you you can't do anything by
yourself you can try but no one does
anything wrong hey guys thanks for
watching my interview be sure to check
out the full written interview at new
media rockstars comm and check out the
photo shoot too also don't forget to
Like subscribe between everything you do
anyway thanks guys I'm actually
supporting a show called little
Horrible's by content creator who's
really funny really amazing and she's
basically like him
lena dunham and Larry David
as that should be watching
the worst luck ever yeah you know what
yeah we didn't cut that right you want
me that in there you'll find it